The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --get started.
What do you think are some
important new concepts
that we've been talking
about in the last week?
Make a list.
Betsy.
AUDIENCE: Various
ways to calculate
kinetic energy [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right?
AUDIENCE: Virtual work.
PROFESSOR: Virtual work.
Something else.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: The Lagrange equation.
PROFESSOR: All right.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
generalized coordinates.
PROFESSOR: Generalized
coordinates.
Anything else on your list?
AUDIENCE: Generalized forces.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Lagrange equations.
That's a pretty good list.
Now, we've talked about quite
a few new things lately.
So is there any-- did
you come in here today
with any questions
about something
that just isn't sitting right on
these topics or anything else?
And I think write up a
couple extra questions
that we may be able to
cover them as we go along.
Steven?
AUDIENCE: So when you
solve the entire thing,
everything in general
is coordinates, right?
But say you want to
find the actual numbers.
Do you calculate them
as your [INAUDIBLE],
or do you just [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So this is really how
to use the equations you end up
with in practical situations?
OK.
I'm just going to
answer this one.
So when you choose your
generalized coordinates,
you'll probably choose
about the same ones
you'd choose if you
did the direct method.
So if you did direct method
and got equations of motion,
would you be asking
the same question?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
PROFESSOR: All right?
OK.
So really, you want
to choose coordinates
that are going to be
practically useful in the end.
OK?
And so it shouldn't
matter whether you're
doing it by Lagrange or
doing it by the direct method
to get to them, you're
going to use them
in the same way in the end.
Now, we have two methods to
get equations of motion now.
When you're doing tough
problems, complicated problems,
I would always do it one way and
use the other way to check it.
I'd end up doing it both ways.
If it was really important,
you do it both ways.
And one will give you
insight about the other.
Yesterday in lecture,
I was talking about,
does it make sense to have a
Coriolis term in this equation?
Would you expect it?
And that kind of
common sense checking.
All right.
Any other questions?
Good question.
Generalized coordinates
or forces or anything?
All right.
Let's get on.
Let's keep working here.
So I have an assignment
for you, and it's here.
This is a familiar
problem that you've
worked before by other methods.
And you did, in fact, even
find the kinetic and potential
energies, I think,
last week for this.
So here's a cart with
a rod, uniform rod.
No dashpot at the moment,
and no external forces.
I'm going to give you
coordinates to use.
So here's our inertial
system, deflection of the cart
x, rotation of the rod theta.
We're going to break you
into groups of about-- we
got a big group here-- 5, 10.
Well, I want you to break
into three groups, kind
of like five or six
there, five or six there,
and the same thing here.
And one group each-- so
this group in the front
left, compute the kinetic
energy of this system.
And the group behind them,
compute the potential.
And this group
over here, come up
with the velocity of G and the
G dot VG, the velocity squared.
OK?
And this won't you take
long because you've
done the stuff before.
And then when you get done,
somebody from your group,
just when you're done,
come up and write it down.
All right.
Let's sort these out.
So let's start
with the velocity.
We're going to need the velocity
to be able to finish out
the kinetic energy.
So the vector,
right, and they've
broken it into two pieces.
And since the others, if
you haven't worked on it,
are you guys--
STUDENT: Can you switch
the sine and cosine?
PROFESSOR: I was about
to ask you about that.
I think that that's better.
So this is sine, right.
STUDENT: No, that's cosine.
PROFESSOR: I just erased it.
That's cosine, sine.
This is your l theta dot piece
and you want it this way.
And that's theta, so it should
be sine theta j, cosine theta
i.
I think that's good
for the velocity.
And then velocity squared, just
the square reach of pieces.
So we have v dot b.
We need to put this into the
kinetic energy expression,
but one at a time here.
The potential energy
expression, 1/2 kx squared.
Everybody good with that?
Looks like the spring
potential energy.
And m2g, 1/2 l is a position
of the center of mass.
1 minus cosine l that
times 1 minus cosine theta
is the amount that it changes
height from the reference.
What's the reference position?
What have you assumed
for the reference
position in this formulation?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So your
reference position
is center of mass when
it's hanging straight down.
Great.
So there's your potential
energy expression.
Kinetic energy
expression-- everybody
comfortable with that?
I'm not totally
comfortable with it.
Let's talk about a minute
about kinetic energy and say,
what can we use, what formulas
can we use here for t?
There's totally general and
then we can narrow it down.
What do you suggest?
STUDENT: For the
[INAUDIBLE] you can--
you have to take into account
that it's not spinning
about its center of mass.
So you use the general
mass formula one half omega
dot, its angular
momentum [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so we have
some general formulas.
And let's take a step by
step approach to this.
We have how many rigid bodies?
Two.
And you compute
the kinetic energy
for each one individually.
That's the safest
way to go about this.
So I would stay away
initially from doing this.
You lumping the two together.
So I would take the
two individually.
So if you take the main
mass, the block on wheels,
what is its velocity?
Its velocity is
this x dot, right?
And its kinetic energy is?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So for
the first block,
you have m1x dot squared.
And you're done.
That's the first block.
Now you need the
second rigid body.
So the second rigid
body, you could
do-- the full,
general expression
is one half m2 vg in o dot
vg in o plus a half omega H,
with respect to g.
Good with that, Vicente?
You need it transposed?
Good.
And can we simplify that at all?
For example, is it that rod
rotating about a fixed point?
It's not.
The point it rotates
about moves, right?
So you can't say it's just--
you can't use, for example,
parallel axis theorem
and just say it's 1/2
I with respect to that
point, theta dot squared.
Won't work.
Can't use that one.
You will find, that
if you work this out,
you can say 1/2 I with
respect to g omega squared,
in this problem
it will work out.
It'll come out to that because
this is a planar motion problem
and there's only one
component of rotation.
So this will work out to be
a 1/2 I with respect zz of m2
with respect to g
omega z squared,
in this case theta dot squared.
That's what this
term will reduce to.
But don't assume it
just out of the box.
And then you need this term.
And that's why we need bg.
So you need to do that.
Put that piece in over there.
So we need to-- so what
is Izz about g for m2?
For a rod, slender rod.
So m2 l squared over 12.
That's what you
need to put in here.
We have an expression
for v over there.
We know everything now.
So now let's apply our
Lagrange equations.
And I'm going to need to
rearrange the board here
a little bit.
I'm going to need
that board space.
So our T is 1/2 m1 x1 dot
squared, or x dot squared
plus 1/2 m2 vg.vg.
And now I can cover this up.
All right.
So the next task
is, let's work out,
do our Lagrange equations work?
So how many generalized
coordinates do we have
and what are they?
x and theta, that we've chosen.
Two degrees of freedom--
they're complete, independent,
polynomic.
And we can use
Lagrange equations.
We're going to come up with
two equations of motion.
And we're going to apply this.
That's the Lagrange equation.
We're going to apply
it twice, where
l is defined as T minus v.
If you just plug in l into this
expression and just expand it,
you get-- instead of two
terms, you get four terms,
because you have these two guys.
And this term-- for
mechanical systems,
what can you say about
this term generally?
That's the derivative
of v with respect
to Q dots to velocities.
Why?
STUDENT: Conservative forces?
PROFESSOR: No, just that you
find it for mechanical systems,
springs and gravity, you will
never find that the potential
energy as a function of
time or velocity just
isn't-- and if it's not
a function of velocity,
you take a derivative with
respect to velocity you get
0's.
So this goes to 0 for
mechanical systems.
An exception for
non-mechanical would
be like a charged particle
in a magnetic field.
Then the forces get involved
with velocities and so forth.
It gets messy.
0 for mechanical systems.
So we really don't have
to deal with three terms--
that one, that one, that
one, and then on the right
hand side are
generalized forces.
So we can break into
four smaller groups.
Two groups are going
to do the x equation.
You have to take these Qj's
is this problem are Q1 is x
and Q2 is theta.
So for the x equations, we
need to do these derivatives.
And for the theta equation, we
need to do these computations.
So let's have one
group A do these.
Group B do these and group C do
these and a D group do those.
So break yourselves
into four groups
and we'll do A, B, C
here in the center,
group here, four or
five, four or five,
or group here the C group,
and D group over here.
Do these calculations and
let's get our two equations
in motion.
And when you get
your stuff done,
so the A group, when you finish,
come up here and right here,
write your stuff.
And the B group, write your
answer here, and the C group
and the D group.
As soon as you get it done,
come up and put it down.
We got this term, this term,
this term, and this term.
Did you guys check?
Did you guys get a
little time, B group
to check on the A group?
Which one was it?
Who's checking on whom?
You're checking on--
what do you think?
STUDENT: We got the same answer.
PROFESSOR: So main mass
acceleration, the second mass,
its total acceleration,
these pieces, and there's
an acceleration that's
Eulerian and then
there's an
acceleration that is--
what's this term related to?
You expect it to come up?
And the kx term,
and all these are
going to equal to the
generalized forces
of any non-conservative forces.
So you're OK with this one.
Let's move on to this one, then.
Who's the check group here?
What do you think?
STUDENT: I think they
made [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Do you think
there's a problem here?
STUDENT: There might be.
PROFESSOR: Can you
give me an alternative?
STUDENT: It may be that
their dt d theta there should
be in the time derivative.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So we need d, the derivative of
this with respect to theta dot.
The first term doesn't give me
anything, the mx dot squared.
The third term gives
you-- should give you
an Izz g theta double
dot, eventually, right?
So for sure, this d by
dt, the partial of T
with respect to theta dot.
So we just run through it.
The first term gives us nothing.
The third piece gives us,
with respect to theta dot Izz,
theta dot.
And no one wipes out the 1/2.
The time derivative makes
it theta double dot.
So the third term's going to
be an Izz g theta double dot.
And it's the second term that
needs a derivative of this
with respect to theta dot.
So both terms are going to
yield some stuff, right?
A lot of stuff.
All right, I'm
going to write down
how this should work it out,
rather than try to grind it out
real time here.
Izz
All right.
These are the terms
that should appear.
This is the piece about g.
This is the-- no,
that's not quite right.
That's the piece about g.
This should be about--
and then this term.
That's how it actually
should check out.
Do you agree with me?
Looks OK?
And then if we add to that
the m2 g l over 2 sine theta,
which is our gravitational
potential energy, all of that
added together ought
to be equal to q theta.
So let's move on to looking
at the generalized forces
for this problem.
So don't know where you
guys went wrong on this.
But if you have
any questions-- we
can talk about
this for a minute.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: d t d theta?
So you got to take the partial
derivative of this expression
with respect to theta dot.
This piece gives
you a contribution
that will be Izz theta dot.
And you take its
time derivative.
So that's pretty obvious why
it gives you the first piece.
STUDENT: I think the
problem is understanding
in the first place that
they did [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Then the
second one, when
you take the derivative of
this expression with respect
to-- this is T with
respect to theta
dot of this part,
this expression,
you get 2 times
what's inside times
the derivative of the inside
with respect to theta dot.
And that'll give you another
L over 2 cosine theta.
And I think you're done.
This times this stuff, right?
2 times this times
the derivative
of the inside, which
is-- the derivative
of the inside with
respect to theta dot
should be L over 2 cosine theta.
So you get an x dot
plus L over 2 theta
dot cosine theta
2 times that times
the derivative of the inside
with respect to theta dot.
This is the only term
that contributes is that.
And then we've already done the
derivative of this with respect
to theta dot.
Wait a minute.
We haven't.
This one, now we got
another term here.
So this one gives you 2
times the expression times
the-- this would give you
L theta dot sine theta.
But now you have to take
the derivative with respect
to theta dot, which
gives you what?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Another
L over 2 sine theta?
Something like that.
So you end up with the theta
dot L, L squared over 2,
theta dot L squared
sine squared.
And you probably get
a theta dot L squared
cosine squared over here.
And those two add
together to give you
a theta dot L squared over--
theta dot L squared, I guess.
Those collapse together.
Those come together to give
you the other piece of this.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
one of the coefficients.
But where is the
derivative [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, the derivative
with respect to theta
only comes in in the
potential energy term.
STUDENT: So what's number two?
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right, yep.
You need that.
And so T with respect
to theta, and you
do have theta pieces in there.
And it does kick
out more pieces.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, I didn't.
Haven't even done
that piece yet.
So you do that piece,
a couple things cancel.
And you end up with-- so I
don't have time to work it out,
to write it all up on the board.
But the complete solution
for this is posted.
So Professor Gossard, who
teaches the other three
recitation sections, writes
these up and posts the answers.
And so they're on Stellar.
So you get the gory details
of each of these pieces.
Let's go on to talk
about generalized forces,
while we have a few minutes.
The way it was set
up, were there--
what are the right hand sides?
Are there any
generalized external
non-conservative forces, the
way the problem was first posed?
None.
So let's put in a couple.
Let's add dashpot, b here,
and an external force here.
Call it F1 of T.
So now, what's Qx and Q theta?
That's an exercise I think you
can all go through, but just
check with your groups.
Figure out the
generalized forces.
And do it by imagining-- for
this one, for the x equation,
say OK, you have a small,
virtual displacement delta x.
What's the virtual
work that's done?
Your delta w, then, will be
thing you're looking for,
delta x.
And the same thing.
This is the x1.
And you get a similar x thing
when you do they one for theta.
It would be Q
theta, delta theta.
Figure out the work done
and that'll tell you
what Qx and Q theta are.
So the total work of the
non-conservative forces
through these virtual
displacements,
you can just add them up.
So there's a contribution
that comes from a delta x.
And there will be
another contribution
from the delta theta.
And we can figure
out each piece.
And you assign each piece to
the equation it goes with.
So if you do a small virtual
deflection in the x direction,
how much work is done?
Somebody give me a term here.
So work, remember,
is F dot d dot dr.
And this dr is a
function of our delta
x's delta theta's and so forth.
STUDENT: F of T dx?
PROFESSOR: Delta x?
That'll be some work done.
So that force, external force
moves through the full delta x.
And what else?
STUDENT: Minus dx [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that
suggests then we have here,
this is F1 of T in positive
I direction minus dx
dot in the opposite
direction times delta
x is a virtual work done
by-- as you do that.
Now how about the delta theta?
Somebody else-- how
much virtual work
is done by these
forces F and minus bx?
They're the only
non-conservative
external forces in the problem
are the dashpot and the F,
whatever it is.
How much work is
done by those forces
in a virtual
displacement delta theta?
Hand up back there?
I hear a bid for 0.
What do other people think?
Do those forces move at all
because you make motion delta
theta?
Is there any dr
here that results
because of delta
theta in the direction
of any of these applied forces?
At the point of application
of these forces, do they move?
So this force is right here.
Does it move because
you do a delta theta?
Nope.
And this force,
applied right here,
does that point move
because of delta theta?
No, so in this problem then this
piece here is 0 delta theta.
And total virtual
work done is that.
And you assign each piece
to its appropriate equation.
So Qx, this is Qx
right here, delta x.
Qx belongs up here.
The sum of these
things equals Qx.
And in the second case, for the
beta equation, it's equal to 0.
So let's make the problems a
little bit harder for a second.
Let's put a force, apply
a horizontal force here.
We'll call this F2.
So now, what is the work
done in this system?
We now have an additional force.
Is there any work done
because of delta x?
This is the real-- you
understand this piece,
then you really begin
to understand how you
do these generalized forces.
Qx delta x-- is the generalized
force associated with delta x,
is it affected by
this new force?
Is any work done?
So I now cause this
little delta x to happen.
Is that force doing work,
assuming no other deflections
aren't happening right now?
Why?
So is there-- it's
not allowed to move.
Whatever instantaneous
position it's in,
it's frozen there
in its coordinate.
But if there's an x
component, it moves in x.
So it's angled like
this off the cart.
But now delta x does this to it?
Is that force F doing work?
How much?
So then, when you add that
one to it, we end up with a--
and is it in plus
direction, and it's exactly
in the same
direction as delta x.
There's no components.
The dot product of F2 is in
the I direction dot delta
x, which is also in the I.
So you get an additional
contribution of F2 delta x.
And so now this generalized
force has an F2 in it.
How about the other
direction, though?
How about this now
Q theta delta theta?
What does it give you?
Now, if you now freeze x,
and allow a slight angular
variation delta theta,
does this guy do any work?
How much, and is
it F2 delta theta?
That's wrong in two ways.
Dimensions are wrong.
Something else is wrong.
So let's draw it.
Here is this thing.
Here's F2.
Delta theta causes the motion
of this point in what direction?
Perpendicular to this, right?
So you can think
of it like this.
And this would be L delta
theta is the actual distance
that it moves.
And so can either
say the component
of that motion in the
direction of the force,
or you can say the
component of the force
in the direction of that
motion, dot product between this
and that.
And this is theta.
So what is the component
of L delta theta
in the direction of the force?
That's this right here.
And that's now in
the I hat dot F2 I.
So our delta w in
the theta direction
is Q theta delta theta equals my
F2 L cosine theta delta theta.
And to solve for Q theta,
now these can disappear.
And Q theta is F2
L cosine theta.
Are the units right?
What are the units of this
generalized force, meaning you
got to think about
that equation.
The theta equation--
we talked about this
before-- has units of what?
What are the dimensions of
term that look like that?
This comes from, when you do it
the direct way, the summation
of external torques.
This had better have
units of torque, right,
which is units of
force times distance.
So force times
distance had better
be the units of this equation.
And therefore that had
better be a torque.
Is force times length a
torque, of units a torque?
Sure.
So that's the correct unit.
And over here, for
the x equation,
do we come out with
the correct units?
Yeah, come out force.
This naturally works,
because the delta theta
is dimensionless.
So the length dr, the length
piece that comes in here
stays with this to
give you a torque.
Over here, delta x
has length in it.
And you're just
left with the force.
So you get a force--
this generalized force
for the x direction is a force.
The generalized force
in the theta direction
is a moment, a torque.
All right?
Good.
So we're officially done.
But if you have any
last questions on this,
I'll stick around and
we can chat about it.